c'est grande et titulaire de la chaire
de recherche du canada en analyse
respectueuse de la vie privée et
éthiques des données massives
je garde bon soir bonsoir comment ça
fonctionne
une fois l'application téléchargée en
fait que ce qu'elle fait c'est qu'elle
va demander à activer votre bluetooth et
elle va émettre aux appareils à
proximité des codes et l'aléatoire qui
vont être enregistrées et si jamais plus
tard un de vos contacts et testé positif
il ya un serveur qui est gérée par le
fédéral qui va stocker ses clés là et
votre application chaque jour elle va
les récupérer les clés et essayer de
comparer les clés au code que vous avez
stockées sur votre téléphone pour
détecter si une personne que vous avez
croisé a été testée positive et donc
vous envoyez ensuite une notification de
risque donc si j'ai croisé quelqu'un que
j'ai l'application et que cette personne
là avait signalé qu'elle est atteint de
la coved 19
j'aurais eu une alerte ou me signalant
que j'ai croisé cette personne là où
j'ai été en contact pendant qu'ils
persona oui donc s'il faut que cette
personne est aussi l'application ce que
fait aussi l'application sait qu'elle
essaye de déterminer quelle était votre
proximité avec cette personne non qu'il
suffit pas de croiser une personne dans
la rue pendant 30 secondes mais il faut
qu'on ait été à deux mètres de distance
pendant au moins 15 minutes
et donc si cette personne utilise
l'appli une fois qu'elle a été testée
positive à la recevoir du système de
santé un un mot de passe à usage unique
qu'elle va pouvoir rentrer dans son
application
ok et si elle accepte les codes qu'elle
a envoyé vont être transmis aux serveurs
et ensuite vous allez pouvoir les
récupérer par votre application est donc
mon jeu c'est donc averti que j'ai été
en contact prolongé avec cette personne
là avec une personne qui à risque mais
sans avoir l'identité de cette personne
ni l'identité de la personne ni le lieu
où je me suis trouvé en cette présence
de cette personne
oui c'est simple et donc c'est c'est la
différence entre entre gps et toutes les
données qu'on peut ramasser avec notre
ordinateur notre téléphone qui nous suit
et et blue tout m'est donc le bluetooth
et sert normalement à faire la
communication à courte distance entre
appareils et là en fait pour les
applications traçage de contact on a
comme des tournées de ça
sa finalité en essayant de mesurer la
proximité martinez a donc effectivement
c'est moins intrusif que la
géolocalisation
alors est-ce que c'est efficace comme un
on peut savoir si l'application est ce
qui se passe et c'est le principal enjeu
est la principale question qu'on avait
remonté lors des auditions en août c'est
que à notre connaissance c'était un avis
de pas mal d'experts en août il ya très
peu de cas où une application a eu un
impact vraiment sûr sur la pandémie donc
ce que j'encourage le gouvernement à
faire c'est qu' en ce moment il donc les
gens de vie privée sont minimisés par
rapport à d'autres applis il ya quand
même des enjeux de vie privée de
sécurité et je pense que le gouvernement
du québec devrait se doter de critères
clairs qui vont permettre au bout de
quelques semaines ou d'un mois de
décider si l'application a fonctionné ou
pas un exemple que je vois qui pourrait
être intéressant implémenter ce serait
quand les gens vont se faire tester
on pourrait leur demander dans un
questionnaire quand il arrive à la
clinique de test et ce qu'ils ont sont
venus se faire tester parce qu'ils ont
été notifiés par l'application et on
pourrait vérifier donc avoir des
chiffres sur combien de personnes sont
venues se faire tester leur l'apli et
savoir combien de ces personnes
effectivement été testé positif
ça ce serait une façon d'avoir une
reddition de comptes envers les citoyens
si ça fonctionne ou pas hélas quand on
voit au canada je crois que c'est 6,6
pour cent de la population canadienne
qui auraient été enregistrées et mettons
qu'on serait à 10% de la population
qu'il activait est-ce que ce sera
suffisant
ça serait pas suffisant parce qu'en fait
si 10% de la population l'install ça
veut dire que si supposons que vous
allez croiser 10 contacts à risque dans
votre journée ça veut dire qu'il y aura
qu un de ses contacts en moyenne qui
aura installé l'application donc 6,9 de
vos autres contacts on l'a on sont
testés positifs vous ne pourrez pas en
être notifiées par rapport à cette
application est ce qu'il est clair pour
vous que notre vie privée beaucoup de
gens s'inquiète de cela et quand même
protégé avec ce type d'applications je
dirais que il ya des risques pour la vie
privée qui sont par la conception de
l'application qui sont minimisés comparé
à d'autres mets donc même si les codes
qui sont échangés sont des codes
aléatoire votre téléphone va transmettre
des métadonnées comme votre type
d'appareil est est ce qu'on appelle un
facteur de correction qui est lié à la
puissance du signal bluetooth qui
pourrait indirectement permettre de vous
suivre
un autre enjeu de sécurité c'est que
les gens qui vont installer leurs
applications voir le bluetooth activé en
permanence et ces dernières années on a
eu plusieurs failles de sécurité sur
bluetooth qui permettait par exemple de
prendre le contrôle d'appareils à
distance donc ces failles ont été
corrigés mais bluetooth et un protocole
relativement jeune et donc les risques
de sécurité même s'ils sont faibles ne
sont pas non plus le pareil pour la la
vie privée ok c'est bien on en prend
bonne note merci monsieur garnd pour
cette association ce soir une soirée